federal judge Emmett Sullivan has
appointed a retired judge to argue
against the Justice Department's motion
to dismiss charges against Mike Flynn
and instead make the case for sending
him to prison for real
Jean Pierre ojos justice was judging
every Saturday she's also author of the
book radicals resistance and revenge
were happy to have her on tonight
judge why would this judge and that was
confusingly worded on my part but this
judge has asked another judge to make
the case to send Mike Flynn to prison
what would be the purpose in that given
what we know you know Tucker from the
time that I spent on a bench and it was
a it was not a federal bench but it was
a it was a trial bench as this one is it
is absolutely foreign to any judge to
even consider bringing in another judge
to copilot a case understand this this
is a case that involves the government
and a defendant the United States
Michael Flynn the judge has an
obligation to rule on the case before
him it is not complicated it is a motion
to dismiss with one of the most factual
affidavit Laden support in terms of the
evidence behind it to support the
application to dismiss it's a
ministerial move that this judge
apparently doesn't want to make so he
has to bring in another judge who by the
way is a a Clinton appointed retired
federal judge this is not something that
needs to be done because the motion
makes it clear that because there were
missing FBI notes found in the law firm
where Eric Holder was a partner and
because the defendant Michael Flynn
there was no predicate for him to be
investigated in the first place he was
told he didn't need a an attorney and
then was the knight effective assistance
of counsel all these wrongdoings done by
the by the federal government and the
FBI and then now what you have is the
Department of Justice saying we want to
dismiss this we want to write a wrong
this is not complicated and now they
want to bring in the clowns this morning
it was all the retired Watergate
attorneys who want to come in and
we're gonna bring in someone else to
tell the judge how to rule he's been a
judge for me as much as like anything if
you stick three steps back here's a guy
who's going to prison for lying in a
case in which we have handwritten notes
from an FBI officials saying should we
get him to lie so we can send him to
jail or get him fired if he was an armed
robber I would defend him are there
actually people in Washington with a
straight face saying he should go to
jail yes because it has become the
politicization of the criminal justice
system we saw it in the Cavanaugh
hearings with the denial of the
presumption of innocence we are seeing
further pillars being destroyed in this
particular case that's right this this
defendant was someone that was targeted
by the judge this judge needs to recuse
himself he should be embarrassing for
the robe on he tells the defendant who's
facing five years he says that
prosecutor considered trying you love
charging you for treason which is death
penalty he says you're an embarrassment
to the country this judge doesn't belong
on that case and now what he's doing is
he's poisoning the 2020 election by
trying to make it look like Bill Barr
who's one of the most honorable
effective attorney generals we've ever
had not a wing man like Eric Holder he's
trying to destroy the whole thing so the
bar looks like the the villain here and
by the way what happened to Joe Biden
this morning was a body blow with these
with the revealing of his being one of
the individuals he's in deep trouble
right now but he can plausibly say I
don't remember so he's got that going
agree he does there's an upside to go
and saw exactly
Joe G great to see you thank you